a much debated topic falling through  today the Community Schools initiative  that proposed splitting up CCSD did not  require the required signatures to make  the ballot in 2024. now it fell short  the number of valid signatures needed to  be divided equally between the state's  congressional districts initiative  chairman in Henderson city councilman  Dan Stewart says the Coalition plans on  refiling in 2024 however CCSD  superintendent Dr Jesus Jara has not  been in favor of the initiative and had  this to say today with the initiative  not achieving the valid number of  signatures necessary to qualify this  distraction can be put to rest ending  with we will continue to meet our  students where they are no matter where  they come from or how they show up